[Music]
so for over a year House Republicans
have desperately been trying to conduct
what is their constitutional oversight
duties and properly investigate how the
FBI and the DOJ handled well really
mishandled the Clinton's server
investigation we know she committed
felonies we know she obstructed justice
and also the ongoing Russia collusion
witch-hunt and the FISA abuse line to
FISA Court judges to spy on an
opposition party candidate in an
election year now sadly their efforts
their document requests their subpoenas
they have been met with nothing but
obstruction and hatred antipathy and
animus from the deputy AG was a bad
temper rod Rosenstein and today some of
these House members had a rare
opportunity to hold Rosenstein
accountable right to his face and it
started with his powerful opening
statement from House Judiciary Committee
chairman Bob Goodlatte take a look the
recent inspector general's report
revealed bias in the top echelon of the
FBI
during a hotly contested presidential
election it revealed that FBI agents
lawyers and analysts held profound
biases against then candidate Donald
Trump and in favor of his opponent
Hillary Clinton it is right out of a
novel with salacious unverified dossiers
reports of informants that appear more
like spies for the US government an
application of the aforementioned
surveillance powers to collect on a u.s.
person once associated with president
Trump's political campaign but it's not
a novel it's real life real life now
next the very ill-tempered rod Rosen
Stein who again apparently doesn't like
me I can't imagine why he was grilled by
Ohio Congressman Jim Jordan over Rosen
Stein's blatant effort to hide important
information from house investigators
again this is their constitutional job
at oversight separation of powers
co-equal branches of government look at
this tense exchange it's amazing why are
you keeping information from Congress
Larsen I'm not keeping any information
from Congress that it's approved a few
minutes mr. Rosen Stein think the House
of Representatives going
say something different I don't agree
with you congressman I don't believe
that's what they're going to say and if
they do they'll might disagree but I
think we might think in a few minutes
the House of Representatives is going to
go on record saying you haven't complied
with requests from a separate and equal
branch of government that you haven't
complied with subpoenas and you got
seven days to get your act together I
think that's what's going to happen in a
few and that's just that's not Jim
Jordan I think that's the hell I think
that's the majority House of
Representatives in just a few minutes I
think that's going to happen and I
wonder why you won't give us what we've
asked for sir I certainly hope that your
colleagues are not under that impression
that is not accurate sir it is accurate
we have caught you hide as your chairman
we allow those inside answer following
that exchange the house did in fact pass
a resolution demanding that Rosenstein
comply with the document requests in
seven days or they do face the
possibility first of contempt and even
impeachment and by the way the president
can demand at some point everything be
handed over and that will then be a
matter of law
now although in terms of the president
has that power one of the issues of play
here the house investigation into
possible coordination between the
Clinton campaign and the FBI's
initiation of that so-called Trump
Russia which we now know to be
witch-hunt one of the small part of the
scandal surrounds Bruce and Nellie or
look right there 2016 Nellie was
conducting the opry search for the
Clinton campaign remember fusion GPS
right alongside ex foreign spy for a
national Christopher Steele visa Fusion
GPS all while her husband Bruce a
high-ranking DOJ official was the
federal government's point of contact
for the same Christopher steel rod
Rosenstein is saying he was totally
unaware of the connection really I don't
believe that
take a look you said earlier Bruce or
was not working on the Russia
investigation let me ask you to your
knowledge did you not know that Bruce or
was meeting with Christopher Steele
getting information about
the dossier and supplying that
information to the FBI at the same time
his wife Nellie was working for fusion
GPS that was helping Hillary Clinton did
you not know he was doing that for the
FBI correct you did not know that
correct okay so he office a couple of
doors down but you had no idea that he
was actually the go-between to get that
information another key question was
asked by a Florida congressman Rhonda
Santos and it's a question we have now
been asking right here on this show for
months why is it rod Rosenstein recused
himself from the Muller witch-hunt now
notice a lot of what you're hearing
tonight should be recognizable to you
because we have been reporting this for
a long time and it was all true take a
look you appointed Muller your
supervising Muller and that's supposedly
about collusion between trumps campaign
and Russia and obstruction of justice
but you wrote the memo saying that Comey
should be fired and you sign the FISA
extension for Carter page so my question
is to you seems like you should be
recused from this more so than Jeff
session just because you were involved
in making decisions affecting both
prongs of this investigation why haven't
you done that congressman I can assure
you that we're appropriate for me to
recuse I'll be more than happy to do so
and let somebody else handle this but
it's my responsibility to do it and all
I can tell is it and how do you have
obstruction of justice possibility for a
president exercising his powers to fire
an FBI director that you said should be
fired and oh by the way the IG report
makes it clear Jim Comey should have
been fired so why are we still doing
this with the Muller probe sir I am NOT
commenting on what is under
investigation by the Muller probe and to
the best of my knowledge neither is mr.
Muller right and here we are finally 407
long days into Muller's fishing
expedition congressman trey Gowdy South
Carolina confronting Rod Rosenstein with
what we've all been thinking watch this
from today Russia attacked this country
they should be the target but Russia
isn't being hurt by this investigation
right now
we are this country is being hurt by we
are being divided
we've seen the bias we've seen the bias
we need to see the evidence if you have
evidence of wrongdoing by any member of
the Trump campaign campaign presented to
the damn grand jury if you have evidence
that this president acted
inappropriately presented to the
American people there's an old saying
that justice delayed is justice denied
I think right now all of us are being
denied whatever you got finish it the
hell up because this country is being
torn apart finish it the hell up
that's right Bob Muller Weissman Oh
Jeanne ray are you guys watching what
you've done to the country what you're
doing to the country now rod Rosen Stein
really when is this which on the end and
rod it's your constitutional duty checks
and balances co-equal branches to
provide members of Congress with the
subpoenaed documents and information
they need so they can do your job their
job and check your department in seven
days from today if the DOJ continues
this obstruction
I urge every single member of the House
to now take action to yes move to
contempt and yes impeachment enough is
enough
trey Gowdy was right and of course many
Democrats that is perfectly fine with
DOJ obstruction their friends in the
deep state have a lot to hide now
meanwhile as Robert Mullins witch-hunt
is producing literally zero evidence
that the president ever did anything
wrong well the people on the Left they
are now predictably beginning to unravel
and their favorite new target the US
Immigration and Customs Enforcement
Agency that's doing the jobs that
Congress passed their laws now
throughout the week hundreds of
left-wing protesters they quote occupied
ice offices all across multiple cities
forcing some to actually temporarily
close their doors and these
demonstrators block entrances they
obstructed ice employees they attempted
to camp out in front of the building the
hill reported many protesters celebrated
the news that their occupation actually
prompted delays in some operations at
the center but quote this
may result in some immigrants being
detained for weeks longer than expected
great job it's all culminated today in
Washington DC where 575 people were
arrested after literally storming the
heart Senate building now multiple
Democratic lawmakers they were in
attendance including one congresswoman
from Washington was actually arrested
sadly this anti-ice rhetoric from the
left on TV is even far worse watch this
I think there's no question that we've
got to critically re-examine ice and its
role and the way that it is being
administered and the work it is doing
and we need to probably think about
starting from scratch I think we need to
abolish ice that seems really clear they
have strayed so far from the interests
of the American people and the interests
of humanity we need to we need to
abolish it
eliminating ice for instance and
president drum ice isn't doing what it
was created to do it's being used as his
own personal police force and in those
actions it's actually making us less
safe what you heard is right the left
Democrats in this country literally want
to abolish ice proving exactly what we
now have been telling you for a long
time this election is the most important
midterm in your life and if Democrats
win this November this is what they're
pushing for I've been telling you they
want to impeach Donald Trump but don't
tell anybody keep it secret
Maxine stop saying it next they want to
keep Obamacare how's that working out
for you and of course they want to make
sure that you get paid less they're
actually campaigning and saying publicly
they want to repeal the Trump tax cut
and raise your taxes and of course as
you see they want open borders they do
not want a wall and number five they
want to destroy whoever the president
picks to replace Justice Kennedy on the
US Supreme Court no vision no betterment
of the American people at all Democrats
have no agenda no real plan for
improving this country helping the
Forgotten men and women so their
playbook is all too predictable so when
they use every two and four years a
campaign to smear slander besmirch
assassinate the character of any Trump
Republican and anyone who stands in
their way and we're already seeing this
in the media after Justice Kennedy
announced his retirement as I predicted
last night take a look if you are LGBTQ
if you are a person of color if you are
a woman so basically if you are not a
straight white male in America right now
you are probably freaking out we're
looking at a destruction of the
Constitution of the United States we're
not screwed we're actually screwed for
generations clean air and water that you
use and breathe is it staged you're only
81 81 is the news 79 don't tell me your
minds going cuz I read Bush v Gore and
citizens united you never had one we are
looking down the tunnel of potentially
criminal liability for women who are
seeking to make decisions about their
own bodies it's time for Democrats to
throw down and what I mean by that is
that we've been playing by the rulebook
and Donald Trump and Republicans have
been playing by street rules we need to
play by street rules don't allow a vote
on us don't have a hearing don't have a
meeting don't let anything go forward
don't play ball with this decision oh I
told you if you think that's bad it gets
even worse
look at this disturbing image from The
Huffington Post by the way viewer
warning this is pretty disturbing a
clothes hanger with the words of the end
of row also I predicted last night I
think that's bad and there's what we
Goldberg over it ABC's hit show The View
another viewer warning what you're about
to see in here is pretty graphic take a
look I don't like this line that and
then I as a Democrat or an independent
or whatever it's trying to take away
anything from you I'm trying to hold on
to my personal rights so that you can
have the rights you want see because if
you take mine I feel like you you're
worried you're the one with the problem
if you take my right away from me to
judge what I do for my family and my
body I'm not a little problem with that
you got a problem you don't you don't
want people to take your guns let's get
out of my behind get out of my
[Applause]
once again the media lying about
President Trump the exact same tactics
the left used against President Reagan
and as I showed you last night judge
Robert Bork the same kind of smear
campaign used against Justice Clarence
Thomas all of this and President Trump
hasn't nominated anybody yet and you
better believe the tactics from the left
are going to get much worse every day
from now to Election Day let me just
warn you hold on tight buckle up and
yeah your voice needs to be heard in
November we're going to tell you all the
key races now without a doubt this will
be the most consequential midterm
election in our lifetime